I'm seriously did not want to get Botox
here because I might not be able to rap
[Music]
do you girls ever tease your man's about
certain like them not having certain
things kind of like a [ __ ] thing yeah
kind of like not having certain things
having things like what so this guy in
India his girlfriend was teasing him
about not owning his own motorcycle so
he decided to steal not one not two but
eight motorcycles in order to impress
her
what and he got caught obviously and
still doesn't know them then seven do
they all have different license plates
and he's like you would actually take
off the license plates and they're huge
like him and his buddy would go out and
try to get the most expensive kind of
motorcycles but the cops obviously
caught these guys because they couldn't
get enough of the motorcycles and you
have made a crime for a woman or a
significant other whatever you're [ __ ]
stupid now he stole a dick he enjoyed
this I thought the second time it was
like I'm debating if the first time was
for his girl just to be like [ __ ] and
then me and but either that or the whole
time he just wanted to steal them when
when the cops caught him he was like my
girl was teasing me yeah [ __ ] can't
steal too but I bet you couldn't do
three in there she doesn't even like him
she just wants him to go to jail do you
mind it's crazy because of movies I
think of silly things is not that much
Oh like I think I've gone at 60 seconds
I'm like dude that guy had to steal 60
cars eat accounts of grand theft auto oh
you played too much Grand Theft Auto I
play a lot it's a great game oh so many
planes I'm like late oh but I did I did
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I feel that whole
hangar with any [ __ ] car
in real life he thinks he can not
because you play the game species
teasing noon I got a [ __ ] place you
said I couldn't get any place I got
along nobody did blows a garret showed
me up sends you right now sending my car
yo you send it well get one Steve I'll
get you I'll get you one I want to set
them oh I want to raise money Beast I
only know how to do it no names of
planes no names please
I mean yeah commercial yeah Delta the
game that's a fighter jet you want
fighter jet on that one no f-15 I'm
pretty sure that is a franchise the one
that want IV the [ __ ] Haun what oh my
uncles everyone that's the whitest
[ __ ] truck ever made oh dude the
first time I were going to a Clarkson it
was a Mexican dude on bolsa Avenue f-150
look see a lot of white guys getting my
accents with f-150s how nice is the
synergies in this beautiful the races
are coming together watches I don't know
anyway all my uncle's had f-150s so and
they're whiter than [ __ ] and they're
Balder than me
my boyfriend was white and bald but he
was actually Mexican he just looked
white and bald nice and he drove an
f-150 nice uncle with no my ex-boyfriend
Oh ex-boyfriend no well actually my aunt
is Mexican oh that's nice but this is
some typical Jake Jake a [ __ ] where
jakey people think they're like oh like
an f-150 that's a Mexican for a common I
think it depends on where you are in the
country yeah that's know everybody think
see it's just a Mexican thing yeah
exactly you know to me I will in
Virginia that's a white people thing a
hundred percent Toyota to come on up
Mexicans that's why well tacoma's are
for a certain breed of [ __ ] I think
I'm not into comas at all
I feel like Tacomas or for like it's
just like the the cheaper anywhere for
everyone's the same thing [ __ ]
everything's for everything hmm you
ain't got these on black people use on
the line somewhere TIFF or else you got
a mozart of every race which one's a
small dick truck and if they would've
raised two monster trucks well it's got
a lift kit on it if they have truck nuts
then they're showing you how big their
dick actually yeah or if their truck
makes loud sounds that's another thing
too well if their car makes the last
half of a huge muffler yeah [ __ ] them
your small dick [ __ ] car so what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this Subaru so
[ __ ] loud the [ __ ] are you doing
right now they say they say like team
sube oh my god I can't hear with that
[ __ ] I couldn't handle the power imagine
that guy on a bad day when he's all sad
and he's like anyway we're talking about
this these two guys that stole
motorcycles [ __ ] it was just a simple
fact that this guy ended up confessing
that he did steal these motorcycles but
the reason being he wanted to impress
his girlfriend because well [ __ ] he had
been throwing all these parties trying
to impress her but it got to the point
where she was like hey man you know of
your own surpasses all it takes weird
thing to have your own like the major
mode of transportation over there's like
you don't even have a car I just find it
hard to believe that she was teased
nimona cuz tips first question was so
has anyone ever teased her boyfriend and
just all of us were crickets yeah it's
not a it's not really a thing yeah dude
when I first got my Grand Theft Auto
online account Nicky was teasing me
because I didn't own any cars yet yeah
[ __ ] off she seems like a big thing in
their relationships under Oh piss me the
[ __ ] off do you night yeah you know why
because I didn't have any I didn't I
couldn't afford any cars yet cuz I
didn't do enough
yeah no I can't believe the fight was
that you weren't working you were just
playing this video game hey can you help
me out with this work that we're both
supposed to be doing I was like a group
project and my partner was collecting
cars on GTA GTA oh I thought you're
pissed that I wasn't getting enough car
[Laughter]
accident he had like I made fun of
something about like his dad I'm sorry I
just like we were in an hour you may not
do it out there and then he hit me and I
never did it again oh yeah he hit you
what yeah I mean I but I never did it
again
Wow and then it hit me or than he hit me
and then I never did know I killed it
not like that
I mean like that's funny like just let
me know let me know what the game he
should die yeah find him a like a few
like months or maybe a year ago just cuz
I wanted to see what he's doing I think
he just sells sneakers on eBay what
we're in the face in the car I'm in the
car
oh that would be specific but no wow you
the face oh my god this is serious
that's the first time yeah that was the
first time without the last bike [ __ ]
hauls off and hit you
well I mean it was like I'm like I'm
like shut the [ __ ] no that's not cool
are surprised that we're shot yes yeah
that's scary yeah it was like earlier we
were like you like yeah I'm never
sexually assaulted physically
nah nobody's ever treated me nothing
less than a lady that's crazy
wait none of you guys ever been in like
a physically abusive relationship I mean
I left naturally but there's a guy that
pushed me in the street one time and
then Nicky that's [ __ ] off oh I get
it
before not sexually yeah okay so you
guys have okay so this is like before
that guy's a real big feminist now I
heard oh yeah he's a huge feminist good
though yeah really
Astro yeah but don't worry on his
Twitter it's all about feminism yeah
he's a huge feminist but he pushed a
woman in the street while traffic was
there he's also not a feminist
gaslighted the [ __ ] out of me all the
time but you know he's a huge feminist
yeah
yes like yeah he's a real ally right
what makes you he makes you think you're
crazy because you said something that
happened he's like that didn't happen
gotcha you guys are crazy I would yeah
but he also pushed a woman you're making
it up in your head god I think he's a
feminine yeah he loves women so some
people like that like honestly I'm in
the ball my heart you should go kill
yourself for sure I think he should be
publicly made like like beat I am so
against like guys when they're hands-on
I watch my mom I grew up watching my mom
he'd be like her two front teeth are
false cuz my sister's dad smashed her
head into account oh I am so against
that's it it's really bad like yes of
course absolutely bad but I think for me
because I left immediately after and I
raised alarm flags and that was like
what like six seven years ago
I dated a young guy he had a really bad
temper it's no excuse but on my part I
left and that was it but you're so tiny
we're just mad at the guy yeah no but I
like him on my behalf I left in the
relationship ended
okay you got me back yeah we just want
him to die that's right you're not mad
about it was just like oh my god I can't
wait to wheezes a [ __ ] way it's a bare
minimum don't [ __ ] hit people don't
hit women ever I did a guy dude that
threatened to hit me and I abandoned him
in the middle of [ __ ] Road yeah
that's fair enough
why didn't get a warning no he dies all
in one
it's like violently no yeah I'm great
yeah I don't play this hit it off that's
like a little bit [ __ ] dude it is
bitchin well you know more kids I
remember yes marques [ __ ] in general
you should never put your hands on
another human being especially like
anything just just in any scenario it's
just not necessary always use your words
you can always use your words when you
do to resort to physically hurting
someone is cuz you run out of words if
or not because you'd minami just need to
get some more words you need to get a
little more patience little something
something you know and get over it but I
mean like when that happened to me my
first thought was like this is an
emotionally immature man I gotta go like
that's it that's not gonna be the last
time if you would have said that's true
that it's never one of done typing yes
that's a temper thing he needs to go to
therapy and more than more than likely
he's not going to change yeah and that's
all somebody like beats the [ __ ] out of
him for yeah dude that's what I'm saying
like if you ever see your friend hitting
a woman you beat the [ __ ] I will choke
one of my friends out oh my god
literally probably go to jail for some
[ __ ]
yeah if I ever saw one of my people in
my circle I hit one of their ladies it
is it's gonna be a problem
yeah kick a guy until something caves
the [ __ ] in and I'm kidding nothing
pisses me off one then thinking about
that yeah all buzzy it like oh my god
damn that's crazy cuz nobody believed me
at the time yeah this is not give us
your ass is nice I love you boss
faint hero and belief fade back what the
[ __ ] oh I love you too
[Music]
[Music]